Russian General Election Commission
announced president Vladimir Putin
as the winner of the 2024 election
Putin won by a landslide with 87.29% of the vote
by tally of the Russian General election commission
Putin wins in all constituencies
chairman of the Russian kpu
ELA pavilova
states that nearly 76,000,000 voters
give their Voice to Vladimir Putin
this is the highest achievement of Putin's voice during the
contest the election
with this victory
Putin
would mean going back to serve as the president of Russia
over the next 6 years
while simultaneously extending
his power
which has been going on for almost a quarter of a century
respond to his victory
Putin declares results of the 2024 Russian election
describe how their citizens
still trusted his leadership all this time
explore new ways of getting information
download metro TV extend now